a string of deadly storms tore through
the middle of the country devastating
several communities tornadoes flattened
dozens of homes from Oklahoma to
Wisconsin at least two dozen people were
killed and dozen at least two people
rather were killed and dozens more were
hurt the massive system stretches across
more than 1,000 miles so far 26
tornadoes have been reported across five
different states David Berg knows in
Shattuck Wisconsin that's one of the
hardest hit communities David good
morning Gail good morning it is still
raining as we get our first real look
this morning at the damage which spans
nearly 50 miles 50 miles here in
Wisconsin at this property it's as if
somebody took a knife and sliced off the
treetops bulldozed what was on this slab
but I want you to look at the back part
of the property that house back there
it's as if it was untouched except for a
few shingles on the roof that were
merely displaced as what's believed to
have been a tornado hopscotch through
here ten minutes down the road as the
crow flies there is a mobile home park
that was hit and the damage is severe
video captured from above this trailer
park in Wisconsin shows the power of
what is believed to be a tornado we
pulled walls off of people and then
carried them put them on stretchers leg
injuries arm injuries it's nothing I've
ever seen in my 20 plus year career in
law enforcement downed power lines trees
cut off at their trunks and a massive
field of debris has littered the
neighborhood many call home one person
has died at this trailer park these are
people we work with we go to school with
and and they're our friends and our
neighbors my neighbors are okay
in Elk City Oklahoma a tornado tore
through this subdivision at least 100
structures were damaged and more than 50
destroyed Elk City Mayor Bill Helton the
devastation was it's hard to explain
like some of the house just exploded of
course the member look like they've been
you know blown apart by hog when the
winds tossed buses and trucks in this
lot like Matchbox cars and reports of
people trapped in their homes kept
rescue crews working overnight a 53 year
old man was killed after his car was
thrown several hundred feet pinning him
between his vehicle and his home our
affiliate in Oklahoma City says that man
was in his house called 911 said I'm
going to my shelter and never made it
off his property Norah today if you live
in the Upper Midwest you are under a
severe weather threat stay tuned
spectres are scary David thank you so
much